I want to ask you about a movie yeah
that was actually we realized this when
we first came to this studio Warner this
this stage Warner Brothers stage 15 one
of the things they started to list all
the amazing movies that have been shot
here classics over a lump of time and I
was listening all the great films that
were shot in this studio and all the
young people my staff didn't care then
they said out and then in
you know 1986 this is where they shot
the Goonies
[Applause]
well yes right away the gun he had a
weather guard some people were violent
OOP I know I saw some guy with the
Doudna the goonies t-shirt up there it
was over there he is yeah well my shot
in here my assistant care my assistant
can can recite whole passages full
monologues from The Goonies which I find
frightening that said ah no no no no I
meant a lot to these people because it's
been its 28 years ago that I did it you
know Henry when you made that move I was
seven no no it was 28 years ago and it's
just one of those things that every
generation Dabney you know I have seven
year olds now that are like oh my god
sloth I'm like item not sloth it was the
older brother I understand I'm gnarly
now and you know the beard and all that
yeah yeah yeah while the curious did you
I mean first of all you make this was
must have been one of your earliest job
first job first job I ever had yeah man
I went through auditions and I was green
and I was told I couldn't act and I was
in they were right and then after 350
interviews I met with Spielberg and
Richard Donner and then they gave me the
Goonies I did and it was I don't know if
it's this stage or the next stage but
you know then it wasn't there was no
green screen it was practical so you had
a hundred and ten foot ship they
actually decided they built a real ship
it was all water on the stage and
because we were working on another stage
it was a big thing to finally see the
ship right they wanted a real reaction
so they took all the kids they wouldn't
let us see the ship for like three
months
they backed us into the water they had
all the cameras ready and they said
don't face the ship go down first
underwater we have a speaker underwater
we're going to say action come up and
turn around we're going to get to real
real extra real we actually saying is
amazing for exactly so we go under way
they'd back us in we go underwater
they say action and I turn around and I
go holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and Richard Donner goes cut what your a
goonie you can't say that I some so
sorry it was just really cool Goonies
never shoot a hair here all right